it's okay to be happy and healthy
and that's something
people have to
have that conversation and make that
commitment to themselves
i deserve to be
happy and healthy and what makes me
happy
and don't feel guilty about what makes
me healthy what what
what brings joy to me life is so
precious
it the next second is not promise
be happy be healthy enjoy your life and
be around people who feel the same way
and conduct themselves the same way and
don't let them drain you but sometimes
people you know like glorify this
busyness and self-deprivation it might
be uniquely american who knows but
sometimes people need permission to you
know because i think we also tend to
conflate productivity and busyness and
it's almost like people think they're
going to get a trophy for who's the most
miserable now yeah dude i mean like
people brag about it they're like i
didn't sleep last night i skipped lunch
but and you're like you're pr
how did we start rewarding
self-deprivation and misery because i
think on some level we equate it you
know i definitely learned growing up
like if it's not hard it's probably not
good right you know so i think i'm like
wait a second that was suspiciously easy
and fun and like i love all my employ
we're having such a good time like could
this possibly be good you know so
sometimes we just need someone to say
like it's okay to be happy you know it's
okay knowing when you're miserable your
whole life no one gives you a check at
the end that's exactly right because you
were like i wasn't happy for 80 years in
a row where's my trophy
no that never happens you know but i'm
fascinated by the your uh the skills
from doing stand-up in your business
life we are able to kind of feel things
and sense things you know i can go on
stage i'm like that's a terrible day
they've been married forever that he's
cheating we just feel that's right what
have you learned um about in terms of
the hiring process of like i love
talking about when people come in what's
the biggest mistake you see people make
what's the most important question to
ask a future employee and like what have
you sensed in terms of the hiring
process of who's a valuable asset i.e um
when i was doing a talk show this was 10
years ago at e entertainment uh someone
recommended uh this girl named
lauren greenberg she had hilarious
tweets hilarious tweets and i was like
we got to bring her in she came in she
was not had no writing experience at all
she was working at a company where she
was trying to promote on instagram
these cups that measure your food so you
don't overeat
and
she was miserable in the job and she'd
write tweets from her job and i asked
her like are you dating anyone super
appropriate thing to ask in a work
meeting but
i like to throw people off i don't want
to look at your resume i lied on my
resume this means nothing like your
resume is nothing that's right and so um
and so i was just trying to kind of and
it's a personal show and we make jokes
about dating and stuff and she um had
just uh experienced her mom putting her
on jay date without her permission
with a photo that like wasn't of her
like it was something and she started
bawling crying and then the meeting just
got weirder and weirder and she was
crying and sobbing and then left
and
i knew i was gonna give her the job as
soon as she started crying i knew it
right and i felt like it was kind of
cruel because i was like i should just
tell her right and i was like i'm gonna
let her sweat it out a little bit you
know just let her sweat it out you know
and um gave her the job and she was
brilliant uh lauren greenberg she now uh
is head writer and james corden yeah and
it was like something that ostensibly
seemed like a big faux pas in a meeting
i was like this is important because
she's vulnerable she's honest she has
draw i don't want someone coming in
that's like perfectly together and makes
no bad decisions and has never had you
know because for the job that i need her
for i need that's what i want and need
you know so i'm just curious
because my instincts were just like this
person right is great even though on
paper this went horribly yeah i mean you
know what well i in the beginning i was
interviewing everybody and what i was
looking for was simple are you smart
because if you're smart we can teach you
whatever you need to know
i just need to know you're smart enough
to learn it
are you a happy person are you a good
person are you a positive person
because if you're that everything else
will take care of it if someone can't do
something do you want them to admit it
yeah because we can teach you everything
you know none of this is brain surgery
none of it we can teach you whatever you
need to know that's why you're here i
don't expect you to know it all right we
we want you to be
smart
we we love it if you're smarter than us
please yeah right i mean one of the best
things you know for us when buying the
weather channel
close to 400 employees
a lot of smart people
buying the weather channel made us
better
like they were just so smart who's going
to elevate me who's going to elevate me
who's overqualified that's
all day long when i go to buy companies
i look at that
the human i look at the human resources
i think for human resources that's the
most valuable asset in any company
[Music]
oh
[Applause]